E equals m c squared has got to be the
most famous equation in the world while
studying physics I used it countless
times and saw it derived in lecture
slides but I recently realized that I
don't think I've ever read Einstein's
original paper where heater writes it
for the first time and I'm guessing that
you might not have read it either but
given how ubiquitous the equation is
doesn't it seem important or at least
interesting to see its first occurrence
In the Flesh to read it for ourselves
well here it is here's Einstein's paper
from 1905 where he first mentions the
relationship between energy and mass the
paper is only three pages long and it's
not too difficult to understand so let's
take a look at it one reason why you
might not have read the original paper
before is because it was written in
German but math is a universal language
right so when I first took a look at it
I was scanning to see where E equals MC
squared appeared and and I couldn't find
it to actually spot it we need to switch
to the English translation because
Einstein never actually wrote E equals
MC squared in this paper instead he said
it in a sentence if a body gives off the
energy l in the form of radiation its
mass diminishes by L over c squared
rearranging that sentence the change in
energy L is the change in mass times the
speed of light squared we often use e
for energy giving the more familiar form
E equals m c squared the equation's
message is that mass and energy are
interchangeable the title of this paper
is in English does the inertia of a body
depend upon its energy content we can
read inertia as mass here it was the
fourth paper that Einstein published in
1905 a year known as his miracle year
since the four papers revolutionized
science's understanding of the
fundamental mental concepts of space
time mass and energy the other papers
that Einstein published in 1905 were on
the photoelectric effect Brownian motion
and special relativity they were all
published in the same journal the annals
of physics this one about the mass
energy equivalence wasn't supposed to be
a main attraction it was in addition to
another paper just more of a quick
technical note which is why it's so
short the paper starts off by saying
that the results of the previous
investigation led to a very interesting
conclusion which is here to be deduced
those results he's referring to are from
his recent paper called on the
electrodynamics of moving bodies which
presented his theory of special
relativity he summarizes a key idea from
it that the laws of physics must be the
same in all non-accelerating reference
frames the first equation here is one
from the special relativity paper so he
doesn't bother deriving it again but it
is the change in energy of a wave as
seen by a moving Observer it is the
relativistic Doppler effect that he's
just discovered in his previous paper
and is excited to explore what else it
can do L is the energy of the light wave
C is the speed of light and V is the
relative speed between the reference
frames Phi is the angle between the
source and the receiver the Doppler
effect is the change in frequency of a
wave for an observer who is moving
relative to the wave Source if the
source is moving in the direction of the
Waves then those will appear to be more
bunched up and of higher frequency a
common example of the Doppler shift is
when a car siren approaches you and you
hear a frequency that is higher than
that of the emitted frequency and the
frequency is lower as it drives away the
relativistic Doppler shift takes into
account the time dilation effects of
special relativity since frequency and
energy are related by E equals HF the
energy is also Changed by the same
factor
now that we know how light's energy
changes when viewing it from a moving
reference frame Einstein then comes up
with a thought experiment for us let
there be a stationary body in the system
x y z and let its energy refer to the
system x y z be e0 let the energy of the
body relative to another system moving
with velocity V be h0
that moving system might be our rocket
let this body send out in a direction
making an angle Phi with the x-axis
plain waves of light of energy half L
measured relatively to x y z and
simultaneously an equal quantity of
light in the opposite direction
meanwhile the body remains at rest with
respect to the system x y z according to
the conservation of energy and the
principle of Relativity we get these two
equations where E1 and H1 denote the
energy of the body after the emission of
light as measured relative to each of
the two systems these equations just say
that the energy of the body after
emitting light plus the energy of the
light pulses in each Direction add to
give you what you started with that's
the conservation of energy
the same is true for the moving frame of
the rocket but the light pulses are
multiplied by the relativistic Doppler
effect formula since their energy will
appear different to a moving Observer e0
and h0 both describe the energy of the
same body in e0 it's from a frame at
rest and h0 it's from the rocket the
difference between e0 and h0 will be the
kinetic energy of the body remember that
according to the rocket it's the light
emitting body that seems to be moving at
high speed the rocket Observer thinks
that they are standing still h0 minus e0
is the kinetic energy before the
emission of light
and H1 minus E1 is the kinetic energy
after the emission of light the
difference between the two kinetic
energies before and after light emission
is this quantity here which represents
the energy of the light emitted
Einstein says the kinetic energy of the
body with respect to the moving frame
diminishes as a result of the emission
of light by an amount that is
independent of the properties of the
body moreover the difference in kinetic
energy like the kinetic energy of the
electron depends on the velocity
at this step Einstein then makes a
Taylor series expansion of this right
hand side that means approximating this
function as a simple polynomial with
respect to V over C and centered around
zero an approximation like this might be
helpful because once we decompose a
function into its Taylor series we
sometimes see terms that are Vanishing
in the limit and can simplify the
expression if we are only interested in
finding its limiting Behavior
for us the term V over C is so small
that we can neglect magnitudes of fourth
and higher orders to get the change in
kinetic energy is a half times L over c
squared times V squared
Einstein mentioned that this right hand
quantity depended on velocity just like
the kinetic energy of an electron which
was known to be a half MV squared so why
not see if it fits that form well it
does if L over c squared is equal to the
Mass
so that's how Einstein concludes if a
body gives off the energy l in the form
of radiation its mass diminishes by L
over c squared
the fact that the energy withdrawn from
the body becomes energy of radiation
evidently makes no difference so that we
are led to the more General conclusion
that the mass of a body is a measure of
its energy content if the energy changes
by L the mass changes in the same sense
by L over the speed of light squared
finishing off Einstein says something
Visionary it is not impossible that with
bodies whose energy content is variable
to a high degree for example with radium
salts the theory may be successfully put
to the test if the theory corresponds
with the facts radiation conveys inertia
between the emitting and absorbing
bodies
Einstein was just starting to wrap his
head around the idea that a mess
emitting something massless in the form
of light actually loses mass and that
mass can be transferred in the form of
radiation between emitting and absorbing
bodies at first he didn't quite believe
it and wrote to his friend about the
whole thing saying the principle of
Relativity in relation to Maxwell's
equations demands that mass is a direct
measurement of the energy of a body that
light carries Mass a noticeable decrease
in the mass must then occur in the case
of radium the thought is funny and
infectious but whether God is laughing
and has played a trick on me I do not
know this relation between mass and
energy has been tied to Einstein's name
and the idea of Genius ever since the
reason that you might not have
encountered the original before could be
a general lack of emphasis on the
history of science alongside teaching
but it might also be because it was a
bad proof there are claims that
Einstein's original proof contained
circular reasoning and there are better
ways to derive the same thing which are
more rigorous and more complete the
correctness of Einstein's first proof is
actually a controversy all of its own
here's a paper published last year
summarizing some of the criticisms
including that Einstein's proof contains
circular reasoning and that it is only
valid to the lowest order of
approximation for kinetic energy
discussion boards online about this
topic are surprisingly heated bringing
in additional factors like the
distribution of credit and fame
Amplified by just how famous this
equation has become what's important to
realize though is that the equation
itself is correct disputes over the
rigor of the proof are not the same as
disputes over the result Einstein
himself perhaps unsatisfied with his
original proof went on to derive over a
dozen versions of the same result in
later papers even more proofs of E
equals m c squared have been written by
others if you don't like Einstein's
original proof there are so many other
creative ones to choose from in a
physics class it might be more common to
derive the energy momentum relation
which is an extension of E equals m c
squared for bodies with some momentum
without the first term massless photons
would have no energy for a body at rest
the first term disappears and we get E
equals m c squared and if you're looking
for a mathematical rigor why not take a
look at Terence Town's version of the
proof which follows Einstein's steps but
in a more mathematical language and
points out a couple of places where
Einstein could have simplified his proof
another reason why the original proof
isn't plasted everywhere might be
because of another heated controversy
surrounding it which has been tearing
apart physics for a hundred years that
is the fight over who deserves credit
for relativity and for E equals m c
squared I only just made it up for air
after reading all the criticisms of
Einstein's proof before I fell into the
cavern of reading about the other people
who contributed to the idea and how they
likely deserve more credit than they got
Einstein wasn't the first to link energy
and mass even Newton himself pondered it
back in 1717 when he wrote and not the
gross bodies and light convertible into
one another and may not bodies receive
much of their activity from the
particles of Light which enter their
composition several scientists working
on electromagnetic fields knew that if a
Charged body moved through an
electromagnetic field its mass would be
affected Point care in 1900 derived an
expression for the conservation of
momentum in electromagnetic systems that
used E equals NC squared in calculation
although never explicitly stated
Einstein seems to have been the first to
establish a mass energy equivalence that
was independent of electromagnetic
fields and throughout his life
relentlessly devoted time and effort to
establishing E equals m c squared as a
universal law applicable to all forms of
matter and energy so in this sense it
does seem justified to associate the
idea with Einstein that Association
would come as a curse when the public
started to link the equation with
nuclear weapons after the bombings of
Hiroshima in Nagasaki in 1945 40 years
after Einstein lines paper E equals m c
squared was featured in The Smith report
the official U.S government release
about the development of the atomic bomb
E equals NC squared can be used to
quantify the amount of energy released
or consumed by nuclear reactions which
convert mass into energy if you measure
the mass of all the constituents and the
mass of all the products and multiply
the difference by c squared you get how
much energy is released or consumed
usually in the form of light and heat
with c squared being such a large number
you can see that an extraordinarily
large amount of energy can be released
from just a small amount of mass
millions of times more so than in the
combustion of chemical explosives whilst
E equals MC squared is useful for
quantifying the amount of energy
released it was not strictly necessary
for the development of the atomic bomb
especially since the fission process was
known in 1938 it surprised me to learn
that the neutron wasn't discovered until
1932 27 years after Einstein's paper and
a much more crucial Discovery to the
development of the weapon Einstein
himself co-signed a letter to the U.S
president in 1939
urging funding into research for atomic
energy warning that an atomic bomb was
theoretically possible he would later
come to regret that letter
Newton please forgive me he would write
not referring directly to the bomb but
for standing on Newton's shoulders for
taking his work and questioning its
foundations flipping it building upon it
and driving progress to both the good
and bad consequences
The Mention Of War in this story reminds
us how often scientific discoveries are
tied to both amazing and sometimes
terrible consequences much of the
technology which has improved Our Lives
has also contributed to the destruction
of our climate if you would like to be
involved in efforts to use science and
technology to make a positive impact on
our climate then consider this video's
sponsor Rin
Wren is a website where you can
calculate your carbon footprint discover
ways to reduce it and offset it by
funding a diverse mix of carbon
reduction projects like tree planting
mineral weathering and rainforest
protection one of their Innovative
technology projects is centered around
biochar dead wood from Californian
forests which would normally be burned
to Ash and release carbon dioxide into
the atmosphere is instead turned into
biochar which locks the carbon for
thousands of years the biochar is then
mixed with compost and sold to local
farmers to use as a natural fertilizer
offset your own carbon footprint on Ren
the first 100 people who sign up will
get an extra 10 trees planted in their
name thanks for watching this video and
thanks to my patreon supporters for
making it possible a special shout out
to today's patreon cat of the day me Jin
foreign